lucien jean baptiste ira faire un petit
prêt faute sur lucien jean baptiste
l'adoré lucien jean baptiste a fait le
cours florent en même temps que michaël
youn et audrey tautou et ouais d'affairé
était prête à commencer à 31 noms way
commencer le cours florent
j'ai eu une vie avant et puis à 30 ans
j'ai décidé d avant alors je faisais du
merchandising je pourrais résumer ça je
vendais des t-shirts pour des vedettes
mais plus ces femmes un peu plus
techniquement j'ai organisé les ventes
voilà sur des gros événements notamment
palais omnisports de paris-bercy fort et
voilà et puis j'ai arrêté là où elle est
arrêtée qu'ils aient des petits boulots
avant vous vous y avez vous étiez
esthéticienne l'esthéticienne assistante
de photographes salle de travail en
salle de sport j'ai livré des pizzas
on est servi dans des chichas matin même
petite demande à eric tu demandes à
malibu tu peux les servir une doctorante
en fout totalement yak beinheim qui a
toujours été riche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voyez aussi j'ai travaillé dans une
bible dans une librairie ah ouais ben je
fais mes excuses non les bras mais
tripathi lotus et de travailler quand on
peut vous allez acheter les fournitures
d'école au début de l'année voit ses
démons pour mon préféré
je me rappelle on allait chez chez
auchan ipad aaron mon frère et j'étais
comme un an où elle voulait pas que
j'achète les cahiers clairefontaine il
était très cher ah oui mon frère est le
cas hier mon frère la feuille et glisser
comme ça on dirait que c'est une platine
ouais c'est vrai et moi j'avais que des
feuilles mon frère tu mettais le crillon
où le client est parfois travers deux
côtés car mon frère danny glover et toi
tu as failli arrêter grise mon frère
comme moi je cherche à avoir une salle
d'autres affaires sa mère elle en a
acheté ça veut dire que tu avais mis fin
comme ça pour le genre à nos frères mais
la feuille mon frère baba en double ça
veut dire tu mettais l'effaceur la
feuillade y avait des trous dans
l'attachement crépel y avait des
morceaux de pâtes à la sauce et tous y
passer des examens
non moi aussi j'ai un petit boulot
j'étais heureuse dans un magasin de
prêt-à-porter d'accord le caire
sacha en belgique ça magasin de choses
je sais je connais très bien sasha sa
phase à chaud à l'est d'ailleurs on en
profite pour ses faux-pas sécession
chercher chez sarenza.com également
merci voilà d'autres marabouts cité-etat
news de silex démunis
qu'on a un double jeu taillé pas saoul
mcg était le sien et on écrit même bling
et vidéos de crottes en zoo à oued et
bon métier un jeu mais dsk par safé
révélant récent et ça fait rêver ça fait
rêver ça féret c'est tout ce que vous
avez fait après j'ai vraiment travaillé
jules il était rédacteur en chef du
parisien ouais vous étonnez moi deviner
un prêt oui mais moi aussi ma mère
lucien jean baptiste a été champion de
france de lutte
vrai ou pas c'est vrai ça à gérer face à
l'ess est vrai fort frérot c'est un
sport c'est un sport alors ben justement
votre adversaire et le times
[Applaudissements]
vous pratiquez encore oui temps en temps
mais oui je suis très attaché à cette
fédération la lutte est un sport non la
lutte est un sport difficile qu'on ne
ferait pas de but ce soir l'inquiéter
c'est gentil la lutte c'est un sport
difficile où il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'argent à gagner mais vrai bon état
d'esprit sachs à savoir comme douglas
était lutter lino ventura et et l'utc
voilà donc c'est une bonne ligne est
vrai et lors de la lutte fait les séries
que vous dites tous les lutteurs que je
connais ils ont vraiment une ligne de
vie incroyable
ce sont des mecs qui envoie la revoilà
sur cc c'est vrai qu'il ya un mental
d'acier qui est particulier vous avez
fait de la lutte non lui il a fait de la
luge d'été dans l'univers d'anne il a
fait de la luge sur le tube lucien jean
baptiste a doublé will smith adam
independence day la classe quand je lis
pas fait d'independence day after
effects dont je suis une légende c'est
ça c'était un piège c'est un piège at
the well well well exact je suis une
légende on voir la légende de bagger
vance
tu as pas fait d'autre que minimath oui
oui je les fais lanthier minimale aussi
je sais plus j'ai pas encore tout l'air
de plaire au fc la mode
oui entre autres entre autres mais celui
qui le kiki le double régulièrement
c'est une grecque germa moi je le
remplace les mettait en doute a doublé
également marqué de loris rock brahimi
fox om snoop dogg martin lawrence ou
s'ils étaient des blancs
avant maintien qui a été double heures
ou un truc comme ça qu'a faits datent du
doublage de fois j'ai doublé une
saucisse dans un dessin animé mouallem
de chez disney qu'il en soit cette
partie exactement vrai mini castaldi
j'ai fait des essais pour faire pumba
wen ont un point commun ils pètent merci
[Applaudissements]
peut être mais si derrière ça c'est fait
c'est une poupée naïve jour le français
lucien jean baptiste le césar du
meilleur premier film en 2010 avec la
première étoile mérité il remet à garder
motivés non
vrai ou faux lucien jean baptiste est un
pseudo il s'appelle en réalité baptiste
lucien-jean à deux doigts de tomber
l'ont lu son vrai nom et prénom comme en
voit que des prisons que rarement les
mecs qui ont que des prénoms c'est des
tueurs en série oui mais oui on m'a dit
ça lui des gens meurent oui frédéric
françois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il
soit adopté son réseau on peut pas créer
un nom de famille donc on met deux
prénoms pour réviser valérie s'est pas d
adopter souvent j'ai dit patrice et 3
avec seulement trois points